this is a very important game tonight
we're looking for tyler o'malley to get
out there and give us some innings and
also with all the injuries that's going
on with this team go deep into the game
and this is bounce toward the middle of
the diamond and odd through another
knock
as you see the ball snake on that uh
grass
rymel toppi has got a nine game hitting
streak he just hits
hard ground ball to short underhand flip
to jonathan india relay to first in time
double play
[Applause]
put a little more pressure on yourself
bounce to farmer short way to india
and eventic
o'malley gets a couple of ground balls
scoreless game mid one
and for kyle freeland this is his fourth
start since his return
and the fastball command not quite where
he has wanted it to be was a left-handed
pitcher who pitched to contact
you don't think his team's going to
catch the ball behind him you better
believe it
as jesse winker does what jesse winker
does
it's now an eight-game hit streak for
weaker castiano's hitting
3-57-12 homer's 33 knocked in
rocked into right center field jana
pendaza healthy retreat no chance it's
gone
a drill two run homer by nick
castillamos two nothing reds
well that was an absolute laser and he
just got some kind of power behind that
ball it just kept right on going
talk about hitting the ball on the
screws
they've come out aggressive tyler
stevenson
is gonna ground to uh
mcmahon who gets help from crowing at
first two outs
putting up the power numbers they can
put up some runs
that's a good sequence there as
freelance vato to chase he gets his
first strikeout
bottle adjusts he hugs a little tighter
to the line outfield grass
swinging a miss
the splitter from allie is darn good
3-2 to third nice range to his left
suarez
o'malley
getting ground balls galore one two
three in a perfect second
hammered by suarez left field down base
hit to the wall toppy has got an arm but
he just now gathers and suarez already
shoots to second a standing double scott
heinemann just one for 14 that one was a
homer
heinemann
one upset
devastated to the second deck
two hits on the year both have left the
yard and a pair of two-run taters the
reds in front four to nothing a lot of
action for jonathan india
that one hit pretty well
but india going deep since he had
started in the outfield grass gets
himself a put out some unfair pitcher to
pitcher
activity
five at 94 second strikeout for maui
oh set him up there he did not think
fastball away a rare off-balance swing
at this and a perfect ending again for
tyler malik
and this ball is a diving stop by rogers
and he gets his man and i think winker
pointing at him saying nice play man
three times he pointed out him he's
still
we're watching him walk off the field
he's still looking over rogers yeah
that's a great play it skips right off
the grass and
winker's already pointing to it before
he even gets to first
pay off
misses and castillano's walks
will head past the glove of mcmahon
castellanos rips through second base he
claims third first and third
with one out
the reds runners at first and third base
for joey vada
clubs that bowl pretty deep left center
field outfielders watching god
home runs in back-to-back games vervato
and that three-run shot makes it 7-0 the
blowout is on
and he ties tony perez
fifth in reds history career hit 1934
fairly well hit to left
winker
makes the grab
and molly eventually walked him here's
the pitch breaking ball grounded to the
right side india fields and flips to
first in time
and that is out number two
that one popped up farmer makes the call
another one two three inning for tyler
malley he has faced one over the minimum
setting down 10. castellanos has gone
yard you saw heidemann joey votto has
also gone deep
his farmer cranks that one a deep left
field how about a fourth home run for
the reds today
it is batting practice at great american
ballpark and it's eight
nothing we'll try and finish off mali
here 02 pitch breaking ball swinging and
a miss and
he gets malley for his second strikeout
swing and a miss
and to your point he has pitched to more
contact today a lot of ground balls
including the double play that's only
his fourth
strikeout one two
check swing he went stevenson can't find
the ball
throw down
safe
oh nice snow cone snare
sliding pirouette the pop and throw from
farmer
tyler stevenson has reached on error and
scored
well hit center field dazza in deep
retreat tyler stevenson to center field
the reds are routing the rockies
eight base hits
five of them obliterated home runs
[Applause]
not sure if this is fair or foul
it is
foul in and out that's played by connor
joe right by the wall of course the ball
finds you and joe getting an opportunity
in left field
showing some versatility showing some
athleticism we always knew it was there
and charlie has an 11-game hitting
streak
joe to third base is loaded for story
and that goes to the backstop and the
rockies will score
stevenson had no idea where it was
connor joe comes home nine 9-1
going to third is choppy at a second
blackman that's ready here's the 1-2
pitch
and a fastball up and in did he go yes
he did
story tried to check but he went around
number six for mali two of his six
strikeouts have come against the guy at
the plate ryan mcmahon
yeah this ball is swatted pretty well to
right center field and it is going to
climb out of here hog run riot mcmahon a
three-run shot
and it's now nine to four
on mac's 14th of the year
this has to feel so good for mcmahon
set the tone
well hit to short story can't get it
winker right through second base tapia
from center fires to second winkers got
third
nick castellos aboard for a third time
tonight two hits and a walk castillano's
breaks and that pitch didn't break much
out of the zone ball four bases loaded
for votto
four pitch walk
a run home double digits for the reds 10
to 4.
another walk
back to back walks with the bases full
11
reds as castellano scores
[Music]
on the ground to short trevor
to fuentes and that'll end the inning
two more runs for cincinnati
brendan rodgers hit the ball hard a
couple of times tonight
this ball is hammered and that's home
run number three
for brendan rodgers and he is starting
to figure out this major league thing
isn't he
i mean this is rattlesnake quick inside
with the fastball and hendrix has been
dominating
in the at-bats that he's seen so far
tonight
this is just bad speed
strike three
and that's number 11 for reds pitchers
which means free pizza first 2 000 fans
the reds win it powered by five homers
they clump colorado and cincinnati has
won six of its last eight